[موسيقى]
20 يوليو 1969 تتويجًا لما يقرب
من عقد من العمل أدى إلى
نصف قرن من الابتكارات التكنولوجية
، حيث هبط برنامج أبولو 12 رجلاً على
القمر في فترة تقل عن أربع سنوات
ولكن البشر لم يعودوا منذ عام 1972
.تريد الآن ناسا تغيير ذلك من خلال
مهمات أرتميس في الأساطير اليونانية ،
كانت أرتميس الأخت التوأم لأبولو في
إيماءة إلى خطط الإلهة ناسا
لإرسال أول امرأة بالإضافة إلى
أول شخص ملون إلى سطح القمر.
كان هدفًا متحركًا تم
التخطيط له لأول مرة في عام 2028 ، أصبح الهدف
الآن عام 2025 ، لكن الهدف أكبر من
بضع أحذية على الأرض
هذه المرة تريد ناسا إنشاء
قاعدة دائمة على القمر من خلال تعلم
كيفية العيش والعمل هناك ، على أمل
أن يكون رواد الفضاء  سيأخذ
هذه المعرفة في نهاية المطاف إلى المريخ الحدودي التالي ،
ولكن على مدار العقد القادم أو نحو ذلك ، ينصب التركيز
على القمر ، وإليك كيفية قيام ناسا
بتحقيق ذلك ، حيث
يسافر رواد الفضاء إلى القمر على
متن مركبة أوريون الفضائية.  في الجزء العلوي من
أقوى صاروخ قامت ناسا ببنائه على الإطلاق ،
سيلتقي أوريون ببوابة
محطة فضائية تدور حول القمر من
هناك سينتقل رواد الفضاء إلى
مركبة هبوط على سطح القمر قابلة لإعادة الاستخدام بناها
شريك تجاري مثل سبيس إكس على عكس
أبولو ، ستسمح محطة البوابة الفضائية
بالوصول إلى  المزيد من مناطق
القمر ستكون أيضًا موطنًا
للتجارب العلمية وتخطط ناسا
لإرسال رواد فضاء باستمرار إلى القمر
لسنوات قادمة بعد المرحلة الأولى
من أرتميس ،
لكن الوصول إلى هناك لن يكون سهلاً ، فهو
علم الصواريخ بعد كل ما سنقوم به  لا تطير
رواد الفضاء حتى يصبح الوضع آمنًا
، وإذا كان ذلك يعني أن هناك تأخيرًا ،
فسنقوم بالفعل بتأخير برنامج أرتميس
الذي عانى من تأخيرات حرجة
أعاقت اختبارات ما قبل الإطلاق بسبب
مشاكل في تحميل الوقود
وصمام فحص الهيليوم المعطل
، المشكلة الأولى هي سلامة
يتمتع برنامج أرتميس بدعم نادر من
الحزبين في الكونجرس ، قد
تتفاجأ ولكن أعتقد أنه يجب علينا توفير
أكبر قدر ممكن من الموارد  ces في ذلك بقدر ما
نستطيع ، تريد هذه اللجنة الفرعية صنع
زوج الأحذية التالي على القمر
في الولايات المتحدة ويسعدني أن هذه
الإدارة تواصل هذا
الهدف حيث اقترحت إدارة بايدن
7.5 مليار دولار لأرتميس في
السنة المالية 2023
ولكنها استمرت  التمويل ليس ضمانًا
للأسف عبر جميع
زلات جدول برامج ناسا الرئيسية
وقد زادت تجاوزات التكاليف للعام السادس
على التوالي مع
تجاوزات تراكمية لمشروعك الرئيسي الآن
تتجاوز 12.6 مليار دولار في عام 2019
قدرت ناسا أن الأمر سيستغرق 20 إلى 30
مليار دولار للحصول عليه  عاد البشر
إلى القمر ، لكن المفتش العام لوكالة ناسا
يقول إن هذا لن يكون قريبًا ،
ويقدر أن البرنامج بأكمله
سيكلف 93 مليار دولار بحلول عام 2025.
سواء حصل على تمويل كامل أم لا ، فإن ناسا
تؤكد أن الهبوط على القمر
سيحدث نحن  نعود إلى القمر ولكن
هذه المرة سنعود
لنتعلم البقاء
لتطوير أنظمة جديدة تقنيات
جديدة تقنيات جديدة
حول كيفية العيش في  في وقت طويل في تلك
البيئة المعادية
لأننا
عندما نذهب
إلى المريخ ،
علينا أن نتعلم أنه
في عام 1969 ، نقلت أبولو البشرية إلى
آفاق جديدة بحلول عام 2025 ، يمكن لأرتميس إعدادها
لعوالم جديدة
[موسيقى]